bonjour Annie Genevard merci beaucoup
d'être notre invité politique ce matin
député du Doubs présidente des
républicains en étant centre pendant 20
minutes pour un interview en partenariat
avec la presse régionale représentée par
Stéphane Vernet de westfrance bonjour
Stéphane bonjour
Annie
nationale vous n'avez voté aucune
d'émotions de censure ni celle au
pluriel de la nuque ni celle du
rassemblement national ni même déposer
la vôtre êtes-vous ce matin clairement
dans l'opposition
avec tout à fait on n'a pas fait échouer
la censure on s'est opposé à ceux pour
lesquels les moyens
importent peu pourvu qu'elles deviennent
le chaos voilà un de mes collègues a dit
c'est l'union des désordres c'est un
petit coup politique pour mettre un peu
plus la pression sur le gouvernement
mais en réalité chacun savait que
c'était un jeu de dus puisque il ne
parviendrait pas à renverser le
gouvernement et puis quand bien même
avec les voix des républicains ça aurait
pu marcher vous qui avez sauvé le
gouvernement non on n'a pas sauvé le
gouvernement on agit en responsabilité
ça fait quelques semaines que nous
travaillons à l'Assemblée nationale
imaginons que la motion de censure est
aboutie et que nous ayons mêlé nos voix
à celle de la de la France insoumise et
du rassemblement national que
n'aurait-on dit des républicains dans
cette alliance contre nature et puis
enfin l'essentiel n'est pas là
l'essentiel c'est que si le gouvernement
tombe aujourd'hui
Emmanuel Macron dit sous l'Assemblée
nationale ce sont des semaines
d'inaction politique au moment même où
les Français souffrent terriblement où
il y a une crise sociale et économique
énergétique c'est que ça c'est aussi le
risque que le groupe les républicains
soit moins de riz en cas de dissolution
et en cas de nouvelles vous savez en la
matière nul ne peut prévoir ce que donne
une dissolution on est payé pour le
savoir je rappelle 97 donc je pense
qu'il est prudent de ne pas se livrer à
des conjectures hasardeuses on agit en
responsabilité en responsabilité
on n'est pas prêt nous à toutes les
compromissions pour gagner une élection
ou pour accéder au pouvoir donc il y a
aussi l'esprit de responsabilité qui
doit prévaloir en la matière ça veut pas
dire du tout un blanc simple pour le
gouvernement ni on va y revenir mais
juste un mot sur le choix de Marine le
penchant un peu surprise marine le qui a
annoncé hier qu'elle voterait et qui a
voté du rassemble ont voté la motion de
censure de l'anus ça vous a surpris que
ce que vous avez pensé de se
positionnement alors je pense que elle a
voulu faire un coup politique mais la
cible c'est nous c'est pour pouvoir dire
d'ailleurs les réactions de ces troupes
sont tout à fait caractéristiques c'est
pour pouvoir dire voyez les républicains
soutiennent le gouvernement ce qui est
absolument faux on l'a démontrer dans
tous les débats et dans nos prises de
position successives on a fait avancer
un certain nombre de sujets qui sont
utiles aux français quand on augmente le
crédit d'impôt pour la garde d'enfants
on fait œuvre utile pour les français
quand on fait voter une diminution du
prix du litre carburant on fait œuvre
utile pour les Français lorsqu'on baisse
on demande à baisser la fiscalité des
entreprises ont fait œuvre utile pour
les Français en réalité la cible c'est
nous on voit bien que Marine Le Pen et
engagée dans une processus où elle veut
se substituer à l'air on est un peu le
dernier rempart et donc voilà la cible
c'est nous et c'est pas et c'est pas le
gouvernement en réalité parce qu'elle
savait très bien quand Salian avec la
nuque elle ne ferait pas tomber le
gouvernement et ça fait mal la cible
c'est vous est-ce que vous êtes le
dernier rempart dites-vous mais est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui au sein du groupe les
républicains l'assemblée vous êtes 62
est-ce qu'il y a une unité où est-ce que
contrairement à ce qu'on va comme on
peut l'entendre beaucoup il y a une
espèce de désordre vous êtes 62
travailleurs indépendants il y a pas de
ligne il y a comment comment est-ce que
vous pouvez faire rempart comment est-ce
que vous pouvez avoir cette unité si
vous-même vous êtes divisé au sein de ce
groupe
la presse dit beaucoup ce que vous venez
de dire
je crois qu'il faut passer exagérer
d'abord sur la question de la ligne vous
ne trouverez pas républicain qui vous
dira qu'il n'est pas en accord avec un
certain nombre de fondamentaux que sont
le respect de l'autorité publique
le l'importance de nez au travail
l'importance accordée à la solidarité
bien comprise l'importance attachée au
territoire à la décentralisation tout ça
c'est notre corpus commun et personne
n'en dit ce qu'on vient chez nous après
il nous faut trouver un rythme dans
cette nouvelle configuration
je ne vois pas de différence
insurmontable entre nous mais il est
clair que on est sorti très affaiblie de
la présidentielle on est sorti pas aussi
affaibli que certains l'aurai voulu ou
le prédisait des législatives on
occupe la ligne qui est la plus
responsable mais la plus difficile à
expliquer une ligne de responsabilité
qui fait que on ne s'oppose pas par
principe par presque de façon
pavlovienne on est là dans le
rendez-vous de la responsabilité ce qui
nous a conduit à faire accepter encore
une fois un certain nombre de mesures le
Sénat est en train d'examiner la loi
travail on a fait adopter une mesure
très importante qui assimile l'abandon
de poste à la démission et qui n'ouvre
pas droit au chômage ça c'est très
important il faut nous avons notre
boussole et et et elle est intangible
c'est l'intérêt des Français maintenant
le jour où ça sera plus possible de
soutenir ce gouvernement parce que
décidément il n'y aura rien à attendre
de lui et bien nous déposerons dans son
discours Olivier Marleix votre président
de groupe il a dit les républicains
n'hésiteront pas à déposer eux-mêmes une
motion bien sûr si les circonstances
l'exigent c'est quoi les circonstances
écoutez si véritablement Emmanuel Macron
ne réformait pas ce à quoi finalement il
nous a habitués c'est attentisme c'est
ce qui a caractérisé tout le premier
quinquennat s'il n'y avait aucune des
réformes dont la France a un impérieux
besoin si le désordre était tel ici ou
là que il faille remettre à zéro
démocratiquement les choses par une
élection nous prendrions sans aucun
doute nos responsabilités la possibilité
dissolution en réalité
l'arme de la dissolution c'est nous qui
l'avons nous le savons bien mais ce
n'est pas une arme qu'on utilise un
considérément ça fait une poignée de
semaine qu'on était élu quel sens
donnerait-on à une
renversement du gouvernement alors que
nous avons si peu siégé et que nous
avons déjà nous les républicains
démontrer que nous étions utiles est-ce
qu'on peut imaginer est-ce qu'on peut
imaginer un accord autour de la grande
réforme qui fait parler tout le monde
celle des retraites la réforme à venir
ce serait quoi les conditions pour vous
entendre avec le gouvernement autour de
ce projet là on a
toujours prôné une réforme des retraites
que qui est rendue aujourd'hui
absolument nécessaire le Comité
d'Orientation des Retraites le dit très
clairement soit vous baissez les
pensions soit vous augmentez les
contrées les cotisations
soit vous jouez sur la durée de
cotisation et sur l'âge nous on a
toujours été invariant sur ce sur ce
sujet donc
avant de répondre à votre question
j'attends de voir le texte que le
gouvernement posera sur la table des
députés parce que sous le président
quinquennat il y a eu des concertations
sans fin qui nous abouti à rien une
réforme
doutait que la sensation d'aboutisse
encore à rien bracadabrantesque qui n'a
abouti à rien pour douter que ça soit le
cas qui a un nouveau recul du
gouvernement moi j'attends de voir je
sais que c'est une réforme que le
gouvernement c'est indispensable mais
qu'il juge politiquement
embarrassant donc comment traitera-t-il
politiquement la question il est clair
que nous on continu à mettre la certaine
qu'elle aille jusqu'au bout c'est ce que
vous dites
jusqu'au bout non en effet sur les la
question des majorités donc sur la
réforme des retraites on a bien compris
vous attendez de voir le texte il a dit
autre chose il y a Olivier marlacidi il
y a des majorités possibles le pays
n'est pas condamné au blocage c'est ce
qu'il a dit à Elisabeth ça veut dire que
cette majorité possible c'est avec vous
clairement non ça veut dire que lorsque
le gouvernement propose des choses qui
sont qui sont utiles qui sont
ajustées à la situation
pour on peut tenir comme ça pendant cinq
ans avec un cas par cas sur certains
textes c'est tenable pour vous ça c'est
ça c'est le problème du gouvernement
elle vautre ça c'est le problème du
gouvernement en réalité parce que
il a une majorité relative et divisée
et divisé parce que on se plaît à
souligner les divisions de notre groupe
mais j'aimerais que l'on se penche
l'avantage sur les divisions de la
majorité lorsque le modèle pose un
amendement qui est que dont le
gouvernement ne veut absolument pas et
que le modem persiste à le présenter à
le maintenir en séance à leur même que
le gouvernement a mis un véto sur ça en
dit long quand même sur la division de
la majorité donc
voilà le problème d'Emmanuel Macron
c'est qu'il a une majorité relative
qu'il a une majorité qui n'est pas
homogène et qui va révéler ses fractures
dans les textes à venir les retraites
je voudrais bien savoir ce que j'aurais
bien savoir ce que Sacha oulier qui est
vraiment un homme de gauche va faire sur
l'immigration j'aurais bien le savoir ce
que le président de la commission des
lois va faire sur la loi immigration
donc tout ça ce sont des
c'est ce que vous leur dites alors nous
sur ces sujets là on a posé très
clairement les termes du débat si le
compte n'y est pas je ne vois pas
pourquoi on soutiendrait le gouvernement
si maintenant le compte est si on a été
l'aiguillon qui pousse la majorité à
agir qu'il adopte qu'il vient sur nos
positions qu'il vient sur nos positions
et non pas nous à eux et bien là quelle
raison aurions-nous de ne pas voter ses
dispositions ça veut pas dire que on se
rallie à la majorité moi je pense que
les républicains ont reçu un héritage
politique dont il d'une certaine façon
qu'ils ont le devoir de transmettre et
rejoindre la majorité c'est faire courir
le risque assez héritage de se dissoudre
et de s'oublier et ça ça n'est pas
possible une dernière question sur sur
le budget à la séquence qu'on est en
train de vivre entre le projet de loi de
finance en deux parties le PLFSS le
projet de loi de finance sur la sécurité
sociale En cas de partie dont deux
seront rarement discutés et un éventuel
projet de loi de finances rectificative
est-ce qu'on va avoir d'ici la fin de
l'année des séquences avec une quinzaine
de 49-3 chaque fois l'assemblée entre la
première lecture la nouvelle lecture la
l'élection définitive etc est-ce que
vous pensez qu'à chaque fois on aura
droit à une motion de de censure ou
plusieurs et que en fait le Parlement va
pendant quasiment trois mois être sans
arrêt en stop and go avec des débats qui
finalement servent à rien
alors connaissant la nuque et les filles
à mon avis d'épouseront l'émotion de
censure systématique
pour le reste je n'en sais rien il est
clair que là on a la démonstration que
le 49-3 et la traduction de
l'empêchement du gouvernement et
d'Emmanuel Macron puisqu'ils sont
obligés d'utiliser cet outil que la
Constitution
prévoit très clairement
la France insoumise et le rassemblement
national ont choisi de dramatiser cet
outil de montrer que c'était un coup de
force de pouvoir délégitimer ainsi le
gouvernement c'est juste la traduction
que le gouvernement est empêché gouverné
convenablement pour revenir à votre
positionnement par rapport à la majorité
vous avez évidemment lu une interview de
Nicolas Sarkozy un dimanche dans le
Journal du dimanche il vous appelle à
aller plus loin qu'une majorité de
textes par texte à laquelle dont
laquelle de laquelle vous nous parlez
pardon il demande à Emmanuel Macron de
franchir le Rubicon à chercher à faire
un accord politique en bonne et du forme
avec toutes les bonnes volontés
constituer une majorité dans l’intérêt
supérieur du pays je le cite est-ce que
les LR font partie de ces bonnes
volontés
rejoignent la majorité ça voudrait dire
valider
nous sommes en séquence budgétaire un
budget
où on emprunte 270 milliards d'euros
emprunt
inégalé à ce jour
où on fait presque 50 milliards de
nouvelles dépenses où on a un déficit
budgétaire de plus de 150 milliards pour
ne parler que du budget
rejoindre la majorité ça signifierait
valider la politique migratoire du
gouvernement qui a laissé
aller les choses dans un dans un laxisme
coupable dont on perçoit aujourd'hui
toutes les conséquences délétères
rejoindre la majorité ça signifierait de
valider la façon dont l'école est
aujourd'hui gérée avec tous les
problèmes qu'on connaît le
communautarisme l'emprise
d'un islamisme militant les
croyances en termes de transmission des
savoirs donc comment voulez-vous que
dans ce paysage dévasté où on a le
sentiment que on ne peut s'appuyer sur
rien de solide nous rejoindrions une
majorité qui a qui a su si mal géré les
affaires de la France ça n'a pas de sens
non recevoir que vous adressez à Nicolas
Sarkozy est-ce que vous regrettez qu'il
est tenu ce genre de propos et qu'il
lance ce genre d'appel dans la période
je crois que cette question a été
tranchée au moment des législatives nous
avons choisi d'être dans une opposition
clairement pour toutes les raisons que
j'ai que j'ai donné
là où je rejoins là où je rejoins
Nicolas Sarkozy parce que dans cette
interview faut voir aussi en creux les
critiques qu'il fait d'Emmanuel Macron
il dit il dit il dit en substance il n'a
pas les moyens de ses ambitions c'est un
président faible
il dit son échec sur le plan
international
l'Ukraine la Russie
aujourd'hui nos relations avec
l'Allemagne qui sont très dégradées
c'est quand même très préoccupant il dit
les erreurs stratégiques majeures en
matière d'énergie donc
si c'était un refrain à refaire il
appellerait à nouveau à voter pour
Emmanuel Macron parce qu'en gros ce qui
dit s'il y avait personne de crédible
chez elle
dit qu'il n'aurait jamais voté pour Le
Pen et ou pour Mélenchon qu'il ne
voulait pas d'un duel Le Pen Mélenchon
en quoi nous ce la droite n'était pas en
capacité d'être sauvée moi je considère
que
pour moi Nicolas Sarkozy est libre de sa
parole aujourd'hui
comme hier mais il a dit aussi qu'il
sortait du jeu politique qui ne voulait
pas se mêler donc il aurait dû
s'abstenir de de politique donc je veux
en rester là
salut appartient
les républicains tournent la page du
sarcosisme on entend ça chez des
candidats à la présidence est-ce que
vous dites bah oui il faut tourner la
page du sarkozyme aujourd'hui Nicolas
Sarkozy elle est républicain c'est
terminé
alors il garde des amis chez les
républicains tout enfin dans cet
interview très très longue il dit un
certain nombre de choses
auxquelles on peut souscrire ça a été un
grand chef d'État donc voilà on tourne
on n'oublie pas ce qu'il a été on
n'oublie pas ce qu'il a apporté à notre
pays et ce qu'il a apporté à la droite
maintenant il a dit très clairement
qu'il ne voulait pas se mêler notamment
à l'élection interne il ne prendra pas
partie ne votera pas j'entends aussi sa
volonté de recul bon en même temps il
existe un problème majeur de digi de
leadership et stratégie chez les
républicains
donc il se met pas de l'élection mais
enfin il met le loi là où ça fait mal
alors il y a deux choses leadership et
stratégie il est clair que dans les
années qui viennent on aura besoin d'une
incarnation forte parce que
notamment en 2027 on ne lit pas un parti
politique on délit un homme ou une femme
à la tête de la présidence de des
républicains et puis sur la question de
la stratégie vous voyez que c'est une
stratégie qu'il nous faut sans expliquer
mais qui est la stratégie de la
responsabilité imaginons un peu que les
républicains
se mettent dans la roue de la France
insoumise par exemple en votant
comment voulez-vous que les Français
nous accordent ensuite leur confiance à
n’est pas possible donc la stratégie
bien sûr elle est elle est censée ça
ajuster à l'actualité au texte mais
quand même sur les fondamentaux nous
sommes nous sommes d'accord nous n'avons
jamais varié sur nos fondamentaux je
prends deux exemples celui de l'énergie
de la politique énergétique si nous
avions poursuivi la politique initiée
par Georges Pompidou et conduite de
façon invariante par tous les présidents
de droite qui lui ont succédé on ne
serait pas dans la difficulté dans
laquelle on se retrouve aujourd'hui si
on avait
réformé les retraites si on avait
continué à combattre l'immigration
illégale et intensifier les obligations
de quitter le territoire français vous
avez regardé les chiffres l'effondrement
depuis 2012 depuis que Nicolas Sarkozy a
quitté le gouvernement donc en matière
de stratégie on ne peut pas dire qu'il y
a des Stop and Go ou des allers-retours
ou des ou des revirements on a une
colonne vertébrale les républicains
savent où ils habitent mais il y a un
problème d'incarnation ça vous le
reconnaisse mais alors ça c'était pour
répondre à la stratégie après
l'incarnation ça viendra en son temps
certains considèrent qu'il faut le faire
dans les mois qui viennent
d'autres considèrent qu'il faut il y a
une chose qui est certaine c'est
qu'est-ce que vous considérez est-ce que
clairement il faut désigner votre
candidat à la présidentielle dès le
début 2023 alors je crois qu'il faut
interroger le candidat en question
puisque l'un des candidats à la
présidence de la primaire a clairement
désigné son candidat donc je pense que
la moindre des choses
voilà pour vous le revoquer c'est la
bonne incarnation quand les républicains
il faut interroger l'intéresser pour
savoir s'il veut rentrer dans l'arène
aussitôt
pour votre partie puisque vous le
président est-ce que l'intérêt c'est
d'avoir votre candidat à la
présidentielle dès maintenant ou c'est
d'abord de refonder le parti sur les
idées c'est un peu ce que peuvent faire
Bruno retailleux d'abord on refonte le
parti sur les idées et après on se
choisit une incarnation sera tranchée
par le futur président il faut pas se
tromper de moments la politique c'est
aussi une question de Momentum si vous
vous trompez de moments donc il faut
bien ajuster les choses ce que je sais
en revanche c'est que
aujourd'hui le parti politique ne sera
les républicains ne sera plus présidée
par quelqu'un qui a vocation à être
candidat à la présidentielle ça veut
dire qu'il faut reconfigurer le parti
dans une autre fonction que celle qu'on
lui a toujours connu et c'est un
changement qui n'est pas qui n'est pas
indifférent ça veut dire aussi que la
culture du chef oui mais enfin bon
toujours mais donc le parti c'est
l'outil au service de la conquête du
pouvoir c'est aussi le lieu où s'élabore
les stratégies que vous c'est d'abord la
la structure idéologique ou se débattre
les sujets et en la matière il y a il y
a à faire bien sûr parce que la société
mobile étant son changement les
situations et on le voit dans de
multiples domaines exigent des réactions
rapides ajustées proportionnées donc ce
travail ce travail de fond doit être
fait en permanence par le parti pour le
moment venu se mettre au service du coup
ça veut dire que pour vous ni Bruno
Retailleau ni Aurélien Pradier j'écarte
avec ce type puisque lui-même a écarté
sa hypothèse donc ni Bruno retaille ni
Aurélien Pradier n'ont vocation est de
votre candidats à la présidentielle même
s'il gagne la présidence du parti
écoutez
je ne les ai pas entendu tenir de telles
propos en tout cas il faut savoir raison
garder là on est dans l'élection à la
présidence de LR ne mélangez pas les
gens moi j'ai compris je n'ai pas
compris que l'un d'entre eux pouvait
tenter par la présidentielle une
dernière question sur les républicains
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui en reste du
parti aujourd'hui vous avez combien de
militants est-ce que la l'élection qui
s'approche ou fait qu'il y a un regain
ou est-ce que la séquence telle qu'on
voit ce qui est en train de se passer à
la à l'Assemblée à l'inverse de nature à
écarter encore un certain nombre de gens
des républicains
les républicains c'est plus de 70 000
adhérents je pense qu'on tutoiera les 80
000 au moment de l'élection du moment de
la clôture des adhésions le 3 novembre
c'est le premier parti en nombre
d'adhérents c'est sans fédération dans
tous les territoires de France c'est un
lieu où qui a des instances qui se
réunissent régulièrement c'est un lieu
où on débat des sujets où on proposait
celui sur les conventions que Christian
Jacob avait mise en œuvre on produit
énormément de propositions sur
lesquelles nous sommes encore en train
de nous nourrir donc on est parti en
nombre d'adhérents absolument on a des
rampants alors en cotisation payante
sont ceux qui s'engagent qui payent une
cotisation j'ai plus de plus adhérents
que le rassemblement national mais bien
sûr mais bien sûr regardez les chiffres
regardez les chiffres donc
voilà soyons conscients de ce que nous
sommes
sur l'avenir de votre partie puisque là
il y aura un chef avant Noël le second
tour c'est le 10 et 11 décembre est-ce
que selon ce chef est notamment si c'est
Éric Ciotti vous craignez des divisions
vous craignez une implosion du parti les
républicains
je vais vous donner mon sentiment
je ne le crois pas vraiment je ne le
crois pas parce que
partir DLR pour aller où alors je
distingue les politiques les
responsables politiques des adhérents
il appartiendra en tout cas à celui qui
se sera fait élire de rassembler
aujourd'hui
ils veulent gagner demain ils devront
rassembler Erik ce type rassembler les
centrés fera celui qui sera élu devra
ramener les autres mais les autres
candidats devront participer à cette à
cette union cette réunion parce que ben
il en va de leur responsabilité vous
dites pour aller dramatise pas vous
savez le pire n'est jamais sûr on nous a
dit tellement souvent que les
républicains c'était fini c'était en
réalité on voit que on est en permanence
la cible de critiques et data
convergentes c'est donc qu'on représente
quelque chose et ça j'en suis
profondément puisque vous dites partir
pour aller où il y a Édouard Philippe
qui tend les bras à toute à tous les
gens qui veulent quitter les
républicains parce que les républicains
seraient trop à droite ça va pas être
lui le grand gagnant de la course à la
présidence je n'y crois pas je n'y crois
pas parce que Édouard Philippe est quand
même comptable d'un bilan le bilan du
premier d'une bonne partie du premier
quinquennat de d'Emmanuel Macron c'est
lui les gilets jaunes les 80 km/h le
début de l'explosion des dépenses
publiques etc etc donc voilà Édouard
Philippe c'est Macron
un dernier mot Stéphane rapidement email
Macron a rencontré Georgia Meloni à
l'occasion de sa visite à Rome est-ce
que vous pensez que c'était une bonne
chose promise chef d'État à la
rencontrer comment est-ce que vous voyez
ça
Giorgia mélanie a été élu
démocratiquement moi je suis très
attachée à l'expression du suffrage
voilà donc je pense qu'il faut
reconnaître la légitimité le peuple
italien et s'ouvrage d'un grand peuple
un peuplamié un grand peuple européen
c'est pour ça que la réaction de Madame
Van der Leyen était pour le mois décalé
je crois bon il l'a rencontré mais en
catimini le soir en la faisant entrée
par une porte dérobée on voit bien qu'il
assume pas complètement soit elle est
reconnue comme un chef de gouvernement
comme un autre et on la rencontre un
visage découvert soit on considère
qu'elle n'est pas fréquentable dans ce
cas là on ne la rencontre pas on est là
c'est une fois de plus en même temps moi
je considère qu'il était qu'il est
normal de rencontrer la dirigeante de la
nouvelle dirigeante de l'Italie voilà
merci Annie jeune Var merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité la Une de
Ouest-France non le sport professionnel
n'oublie pas la planète c'est à la Une
de votre journal Stéphane merci Annie
Geneva on passe au club des territoires
[Musique]